tomemos el número 7 y vamos a dividirlo
entre 3 y ahora voy a conceptualizar
dividir entre 3 como veamos cuántos
grupos de 3 puedo yo formar de siete
objetos entonces voy a dibujar siete
cosas tres cuatro cinco seis siete cosas
ahí están ahora voy a intentar
agruparlos en grupos de tres entonces
ahí está uno acá está
otro grupo de tres y como puedes ver
aquí nos sobra uno ajá esto esto sobra y
esto es el residuo entonces después de
crear todos los grupos de tres posibles
me quedo un residuo así cuando cuando tú
veas esto la gente te va a decir oh es
que 7 dividido entre 3 con eso yo puedo
crear dos grupos de tres pero la
división en este caso no es exacta me
queda un residuo un residuo de 1 así que
lo voy a escribir aquí 2 residuo
esto literalmente nos dice que 7
dividido entre 3 es igual a 2 residuo 1
y eso tiene sentido porque 2 por 3 es
igual a 6 no llega al 7 pero tienes el
residuo 6 más el residuo si llega a 7 es
exactamente 7 hagamos otro ejemplo otro
ejemplo imagina voy a dibujar 15 objetos
ajá entonces voy a dividirlo dividir 15
entre 4 dibujo
15 objetos 5 6 7 8 9 10 objetos 11 12 13
14 y 15 objetos ok voy a voy a intentar
dividirlo en grupos de 4 ahí está un
grupo de 4 otro grupo de cuatro y otro
grupo de cuatro puedes ver que que no
puedo formar un cuarto grupo de cuatro
me queda me queda este residuo estas
tres bolitas representan el residuo
tengo entonces estas tres bolitas y me
queda residuo 3
podemos decir que 15 dividido entre 4 es
igual a 3 residuo 34 caben 15 3 veces
pero eso solamente nos lleva a 12 4 por
3 es igual a 12 para llegar a 15
necesitamos 3 más entonces 15 dividido
entre 4 es igual a 3 residuo 3 ahora
vamos a intentar hacer esto usando un
poco la técnica de división larga de
acuerdo entonces digamos que yo tengo
que yo tengo 4 digamos que quiero
dividir 75 entre 4 usando la técnica
tradicional de división 4 caben 7 una
vez y lo que estoy haciendo es decir que
en el fondo lo que se dice es que 4 cabe
en 70 10 veces ajá por eso por eso está
el 1 en este lugar de las décimas 1 por
4 es igual a 4 y hago la resta 7 - 4 es
igual a 3 esto es igual a 3 bajamos el
5 entonces 4 caben 35 veamos 4 x 8 eso
es igual a 32 y 4 por 9 436 aquí
entonces va a un 18 y aquí restamos 35
menos 32 es igual a 3
ahora el 4 ya no cabe en el 3 entonces
el 3 es el residuo éste es el residuo
así que 75 dividido entre 4 es igual a
18 residuo 3 y ya terminamos residuo 3
perfecto